so I guess just to start off I mean what
is the process to sort of acclimate
yourself to the city of Chicago when
you're when you decide to set a film
here I've been coming in for 22 years
okay so it's there was there was a real
familiarity to it mm-hmm but the fact
that matters reason why I wanna sit in
Chicago was because of all the things
which this it makes extremely amazing
city first and foremost which you know
has its problems and has its issues and
I I think you know as a contemporary you
know modern city you know Chicago has is
extraordinary and I want to take mine
fiction and steeple in a narrative of
here which is political economical
racial policing religion etc etcetera
etcetera and then also geography within
15 minutes you find yourself in the most
poorest parts of America I mean with and
vice versa you find something which is
lost America I mean it's it's here it's
just this amazing landscape to make a
movie make a narrative has the city
changed at all during those 22 years
have you noticed things that are that
are different now as opposed to back
then yes in a way I mean again it's it's
how how things are shifted a bit as far
as as far as population and so forth and
whatnot but economically you know some
parts are worse than when they were that
while I was here 22 years ago what are
your favorite places to go to on Chicago
my favorite places to go to in Chicago I
had breakfast on the top of that was at
the Sears Tower mmm and that was great
when you're looking for locations what
is that process for you how are you
working with your a sorter well as far
as location concern I had an amazing art
director called Adam Stockhausen he
actually is a Milwaukee sort of local
overseas left town but so he knew the
city quite well and also I knew a bit to
see as well too but we had 60 locations
so we really had a vast sort of coverage
of the city all the landscapes and so
forth in order to get an authentic view
of where we are at right now I mean to
basically put this heist movie in the
context of the here-and-now
very important are there any places that
you couldn't use or that you didn't know
quite quite reverse we went the places
with her never been shot before I mean
we went to places where a majority of
crew and never been before I mean you
know what is it like shooting in those
places than that are they used to
filming there or no of course not and
you know they're not used to filming
there but it's kinda like they're cool I
mean you know please were bit nervous
but then people call I love the opening
intercutting a sort of tender moment
with Liam and viola and then cutting
between the the bank robbery what was
that process working with your editor
Joe and figuring that out well it was in
the script I mean again I split but it
was it was exciting but it's when you
actually physically do it you have an
idea of something but then when you
first they put together that's exciting
so that that was wonderful and Joe
Walker is such a great editor I made all
my film to them and we grew up in
inhaling together so I mean again I
think what Joe does is he you know he's
just timing and he was ex musician so I
think he's a great editor absolutely
this one the best
you